Allergies turn your own body against you over
something stupid like strawberries.
We've got to be able to stop that.
Anthony here for Dnews and allergies suck.
There is no more annoying reminder of how
fragile the human body really is than getting
laid up in bed because a pollen or peanut
dust.
And while there's everything from over-the-counter
pills to epi pens to help mitigate the symptoms,
we've never been able to knock out allergies
entirely.
But thanks to some researchers over at Johns
Hopkins, we just got crazy close to eliminating
these things once and for all.
So allergies basically occur when your immune
system thinks that something normal is a threat.
It makes these antibodies called Immunoglobulin
E to protect you from things that cause illness.
An allergic person's body makes way too much
in it.
These antibodies that bind to mast cells and
together they absorb chemicals from your blood
that are helpful in fighting invasion.
When something like pollen gets into an allergic
person's bloodstream, it sticks to the antibodies
and the mast cells release all those chemicals,
like histamine.
That's the one that gives you all the itchy,
runny nose, can't breathe, swelling up sorta
reactions, which is why allergy medicines
are antihistamines.
Allergies can also change over time.
So maybe you weren't lactose intolerant when
you were younger but now, whoops, no more
ice cream for you.
Or maybe you could never have ice cream and
now you're totally good,
but why?
As always, it's genes.
If one of your parents is allergic to something,
your chance of having some kind of allergy
is about 50 percent.
Two allergic parents, seventy to eighty percent.
But other factors come into play: pollution
in the environment, your diet, even your emotional
health, which makes it sound like someone
that epigenetic stuff we've been talking about
lately right?
Like maybe every allergy is connected to some
specific gene sequence and environmental trigger.
Well the team at Johns Hopkins just found
out that no!
One single genetic pathway is responsible
for a huge number of common food and environmental
allergies.
One stupid protein called TGF-beta, is causing
all of our problems.
Now TGF-beta controls how cells in your vital
organs grow and how they communicate with
each other.
Faulty signaling from it has been known to
cause connective tissue disorders.
But here's what's awesome.
See right now, a lot of people are using expensive
prescription medicine or injections to treat
allergies,
but high TFG-beta signaling can be treated
with something called Losartan, which is a
very old simple drug that's been used for
years to control high blood pressure.
Now more study has to be done, of course,
but how awesome is that?
If your body wants to make something simple
like cat hair deadly, well then you can use
something simple to get it back in line.
And in the future just like anything genetic,
we might be able to nip this in the bud and
use some sort of gene therapy or future medication
to change the way TGF-beta works in our bodies
entirely and say goodbye to allergies forever!
That's pretty cool.
You guys have any allergies?
Let's share stories of suffering down below
and remember to subscribe for more Dnews.